bien des dames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens à la suite du conseil de
défense sanitaire qui s'est tenue ce
matin sous l'autorité du président de la
république je veux ce soir partager avec
vous un nouveau point de situation sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie qui frappe
notre pays et faire un bilan des mesures
que je vous avais annoncé le 27 décembre
dernier que nous avons mis en place pour
une durée initiale de trois semaines qui
s'achève donc dimanche prochain je veux
aussi vous dire ce que sont les
évolutions encourageantes qui commence à
se dessiner et sans rien ignorer des
tensions qui s'exercent encore sur notre
système de santé vous préciser le
calendrier dans lequel nous pourrons
courant février levé la plupart des
restrictions prises pour freiner
l'épidémie à la faveur du nouveau pass
vaccinale qui entrera en vigueur lundi
prochain la france comme tous les autres
pays européens est frappé depuis
maintenant près de deux mois par une
vague d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
exceptionnel parce qu'elle est alimentée
par le cumul de deux variants delta et
omicron qui se sont non seulement
succéder mais en fait additionnez depuis
la fin de l'année dernière
exceptionnelle surtout en raison de
l'extrême contagiosité du variant
omicron dont on sait qu'il a déjà touché
plus de 5 millions d'entre nous et
probablement au moins le double si on
ajoute le nombre estimé de ceux qui ne
sont pas allés se faire tester faute de
symptômes notable oui notre pays
traverse depuis quelques semaines une
phase difficile
d'abord à l'hôpital où la tension reste
forte même si la mobilisation
remarquable de nos soignants a permis
jusqu'à présent de faire face chaque
jour à des arrivées toujours importante
de malades mais également dans notre vie
quotidienne avec eux le nombre
spectaculaire des contaminations dues
aux variants mikron peu de familles on
est épargné avec tout ce que cela
occasionne en termes de tests à réaliser
pour les proches de contraintes
d'isolement pour les malades et bien sûr
d'angoissé quand des symptômes
importants apparaissent cette vague
exceptionnelle n'est pas terminé mais je
crois pouvoir vous dire que
l'association commence à évoluer plus
favorablement la première évolution
positive est que la vague liés aux
variantes delta est partout en net
reflux c'est très important car vous
savez que ce variant delta était plus
dangereux que les variants précédent
depuis une semaine le nombre des malades
en réanimation se réduit enfin
légèrement et cette baisse devrait se
prolonger à mesure que le variant delta
poursuivra sa décrue la deuxième
nouvelle encourageante et que la vague
provoquée par le variant omicron
commence à marquer le pas dans les
régions où ce variant avait frappé en
premier à la fin décembre c'est en
particulier le cas en ile-de-france où
la décrue est maintenant engagée certes
ce que nous constatons en ile de france
n'est pas encore vrai dans la plupart
des autres régions métropolitaines où le
variant omicron est arrivé plus tard et
où le nombre de contamination continuent
de progresser je veux mentionner aussi
la situation particulière des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
qui connaissent des flambées épidémiques
régulière où le niveau de vaccination
est plus bas que dans le reste du pays
ce qui nous a conduits à proroger l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
mais cette évolution différente selon
les territoires et classique et donc ce
qui se passe en île de france décident
une perspective rassurante et surtout
cohérentes avec ce que l'on observe au
royaume uni où la région du grand
londres a connu son pic dix jours avant
le reste du pays la troisième nouvelle
rassurante c'est enfin la confirmation
que ce variant omicron est certes
beaucoup plus dangereux mais clairement
moins sévère que ses prédécesseurs je
sais que cet élément nouveau a pu
conduire à se poser des questions est-ce
que cela sert encore à quelque chose se
faire vacciner ou de faire son rappel si
même vacciné on peut attraper aussi
facilement ce virus est ce que face à
l'ampleur de la vague mais il ne
faudrait pas tout simplement laissé filé
l'épidémie sans rien faire de prendre
aucune mesure de plus se tester en cas
de doute ne plus s'isoler quand on est
positif je vous le dis clairement même
atténuées ce virus n'a rien d'anodin il
ne s'agit absolument pas d'une simple
grippe un seul chiffre pour le démontrer
au cours d'une année normale
l'épidémie de grippe provoque en moyenne
dix mille hospitalisation sur toute la
période de l'hiver avec omicron nous
atteignons ce chiffre non pas en trois
mois mais en cinq jours seulement si
nous avons pu traverser ces dernières
semaines avec des centaines de millier
de contaminations chaque jour et des
hôpitaux qui ont tenu ce n'est pas le
fruit du hasard c'est parce que nous
avons pris les bonnes décisions parce
que nous sommes massivement vacciner et
que nos vaccins restent extrêmement
protecteurs oui les caractéristiques de
ce variant font qu'on peut facilement
attraper le virus à des temps vacciner
mais là aussi deux chiffres très
parlants une personne complètement
vaccinés à quatre fois et demi moins de
risques d'attraper la co vide et surtout
25 fois moins de risques d'être
hospitalisées en soins critiques c'est à
dire avec des formes graves par rapport
à une personnes non vaccinées
seuls 7% des adultes ne sont toujours
pas vaccinées et pourtant ils
représentent l'écrasante majorité des
patients hospitalisés dans les services
de réanimation au grand dam de nos
soignants qui se battent au quotidien
depuis deux ans de façon admirable
inlassablement je me rends auprès de
auprès des personnels des établissements
de santé j'y serai une nouvelle fois
demain puis encore après demain le
gouvernement déploie dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé des moyens inédits
pour à la fois rattraper le retard
accumulé depuis des décennies et donner
à notre système de soins et à ses
acteurs les perspectives dont ils ont
besoin on ne le dira jamais assez la
vaccination a changé la donne et nous
devons poursuivre nos efforts en dépit
des résultats qui nous place grâce à une
mobilisation exceptionnelle que
l'histoire retiendra parmi les nations
les mieux vacciner et donc les plus
protégés au monde plus de 93 pour ça les
adultes ont reçu leurs premières doses
plus de 91% de dose ou l'équivalent en
plus de 62% trois doses ou l'équivalent
mais nous devons encore poursuivre notre
mobilisation nous devons en particulier
faire progresser la vaccination des
enfants de 5 à 11 ans qui a démarré
doucement même si je sais que beaucoup
de parents hésitent encore je veux leur
dire que les autorités scientifiques
sont très clairs sur le bénéfice de
cette vaccination et nous la
faciliteront 1 autorisant davantage de
lieux et deux professionnels y compris
les pharmaciens et les infirmières à
pouvoir réaliser cette injection pour
les 12 17 ans l'ouverture du rappel a
été décidé pour ceux qui sont atteints
de pathologies chroniques comme beaucoup
de pays autour de nous l'ont fait je
vous annonce que nous allons étendre
cette possibilité d'un rappel vaccinal
pour tous mais sans obligation à compter
de lundi prochain pour tous les autres
nous devons sans relâche poursuivre
notre stratégie d'aller vers les non
vaccinés en particulier les populations
les plus éloignés du système de soins au
delà de la vaccination notre stratégie
de dépistage et les mesures de freinage
prise le mois dernier ont été tout aussi
utile les simulations de l'institut
pasteur ont montré que si nous n'avions
pris aucune mesure le nombre des entrées
hospitalière au cours de ce mois de
janvier aurait été deux fois plus élevé
je dis bien deux fois plus élevé grâce à
la vaccination
grâce au pass sanitaires nous n'avons
pas eu à prendre des mesures aussi
contraignantes que beaucoup de nos
voisins européens en particulier nous
avons préservé la continuité des
activités nous n'avons pas restaurée de
couvre feu et nous avons fait le choix
de laisser nos écoles ouvertes
c'est un choix fort constant depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire qui repose
sur l'intérêt de nos enfants
j'ai parfaitement conscience que
l'adaptation du protocole sanitaire à
l'école a entraîné des difficultés des
difficultés pour les parents d'élèves
des difficultés pour nos enseignants et
plus généralement pour toutes celles et
ceux qui concourent au service public de
l'éducation et de la petite enfance dans
l'état dans les collectivités
territoriales et dans tous les
établissements accueillant des enfants
je veux leur répéter toute la
considération du gouvernement et de la
nation pour leur engagement et leur
dévouement au service de l'école ouverte
au service des enfants de france
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et le ministre de la santé
j'ai reçu les représentants des
personnels de l'éducation nationale et
nous avons apporté les correctifs
nécessaires mais rien n'aurait été pire
que de fermer des établissements
scolaires voire de retarder la rentrée
car la réouverture vu la flambée du
nombre de cas auraient été très
difficile avant-hier mardi
17 mille trente sept classes étaient
fermés c'est beaucoup mais cela
représente
3,2 pour cent des classes en france
3,2 pour cent si comme certains nous le
suggère nous avions fermé 100% des
classes je vous laisse déduire vous-même
toutes les conséquences je suis
convaincu que notre choix a été le bon
tester tester pour ne pas fermer testé
pour freiner l'épidémie plus de 12
millions de personnes se sont fait
tester la semaine dernière c'est un
record absolu
c'est deux fois plus que lors de toutes
les vagues précédentes et c'est
nécessaire pour freiner au micro ondes
pour le faire reculer il faut d'abord
que les personnes contaminées le sache
et s'isole pour ne pas diffuser le virus
davantage encore c'est la base de la
lutte contre toute épidémie je veux
remercier tous les professionnels qui
ont contribué à cet effort de dépistage
exceptionnelle et qui continue encore et
en particulier les pharmaciens de notre
pays mais aussi tous les acteurs tous
les professionnels qui nous ont permis
d'ouvrir 425 nouveaux centres de
dépistage depuis le début de l'année
2022 c'est également un effort à mettre
au crédit de nos concitoyens qui joue
pleinement le jeu des autotests demandé
aux personnes cas contact avec plus d'un
million d'autotest délivrés chaque jour
dans nos pharmacies
mesdames et messieurs
l'ensemble de ces éléments qui sont le
résultat de nos efforts individuels et
collectifs nous permettent ce soir de
dresser des perspectives
comme toujours nous le faisons de
manière progressive et cohérente
l'évolution de la situation nous permet
d'envisager un allègement des
contraintes dès les premiers jours de
février nous pouvons l'envisager parce
que nous disposerons très bientôt d'un
nouvel outil le pass vaccinale que la
représentation nationale a voté et qui
entrera en vigueur lundi prochain le 24
janvier sous réserve bien sûr de la
décision du conseil constitutionnel
attendu demain
concrètement l'ensemble des français de
16 ans et plus devront justifier d'un
schéma vaccinal complet pour aller au
restaurant au cinéma au théâtre dans un
stade ou pour prendre le tgv sauf pour
les enfants de 12 à 15 ans il ne sera
plus possible de rentrer dans ces lieux
avec un simple test négatif
seules les visites dans les hôpitaux
maisons de retraites ou autres
établissements médico sociaux pourront
rester accessible avec un test comme
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
je rappelle que le schéma vaccinal
complet ce suppose de faire son rappel
dans un délai de sept mois après la
dernière injection et que ce délai sera
ramené à quatre mois à partir du 15
février conformément à ce que nous avons
déjà annoncé fin décembre
nous veillerons à ce que cette évolution
ne pénalise pas à nos français nos
concitoyens de l'étranger qui devront
pouvoir bénéficier rapidement d'une dose
de rappel lorsqu'ils reviennent chez eux
depuis l'annnonce du pass vaccinale plus
d'un million de français qui n'était pas
encore vaccinée ont franchi le pas c'est
bien mais ce n'est pas encore suffisant
il faut amplifier ce mouvement je vous
annonce que nous allons permettre à
celles et ceux qui feront leurs
premières doses d'ici le 15 février de
bénéficier d'un pass vaccinale valide à
deux conditions bien faire leur deuxième
dose un mois plus tard et dans
l'intervalle justifier également d'un
test négatif de moins de 24 heures
la transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale est une évolution
nécessaire et cohérente elle est
nécessaire si nous voulons préserver et
amplifier notre couverture vaccinale
aussi bien aujourd'hui que demain en cas
de nouveaux variants elle est cohérente
car elle assume de faire peser
clairement la contrainte sur les non
vaccinés et dès lors de pouvoir lever
les mesures de freinage que nous avons
prises pour contrer la dernière vague
nous allons donc alléger les mesures en
vigueur en deux étapes qui
interviendront les mercredis 2 et 16
février c'est d'élèves devant permettre
le déploiement en bon ordre du pass
vaccinale et à nos hôpitaux d'absorber
les effets du pic épidémique
a compté donc lu mercredi 2 février
tous les équipements notamment sportifs
et culturels qui accueillent du public
ainsi pour en retrouver un
fonctionnement à pleine capacité san
jose en respectant cependant
l'obligation du port du masque à cette
même échéance le télétravail ne sera
plus obligatoire mais restera recommandé
en laissant aux entreprises soin de
maintenir le bon niveau dans le cadre de
leur dialogue social inter le port du
masque ne saura lui exiger un extérieur
à compter du mercredi 16 février nous
lèverons les autres mesures la
consommation dans les stades les cinémas
ou les transports sera à nouveau
autorisée les concerts debout et la
consommation debout dans les bars pour
en reprendre les discothèques pour en
rouvrir j'ajoute que nous pourrons aussi
envisagée au retour des vacances
scolaires de février un allègement du
poteau coach scolaire sur la levée du
port du masque pour les élèves dans les
écoles élémentaires ou sur la question
du nombre de tests ou d'auto tests à
réaliser nous consulterons bien sûr à
cet effet les autorités sanitaires
je sais que cette perspective de reprise
d'allègement et est attendu l'approchent
graduée et progressive que nous retenons
appelle évidemment de la part de chacune
et chacun un respect strict des règles
du jeu jusqu'à leur terme de même nous
maintiendrons évidemment jusqu'à ses
échéances tous les dispositifs de
soutien économique que subissent
aujourd'hui
l'impact de nos mesures je pense en
particulier aux hôtels cafés restaurants
et traiteurs mais aussi au secteur de
l'événementiel du sport et de la culture
que nous aiderons comme à chaque fois à
passer le cap au delà de quoi l'avenir
sera t-il fait sur le plan sanitaire
cette question appelle forcément à
l'humilité et à la prudence nos
autorités scientifiques ne savent pas
nous dire si le variant omicron marque
une étape décisive sur la voie d'une
banalisation du virus ou bien si nous
restons encore exposés aux risques
qu'apparaissent de nouveaux variants
problématique mon gouvernement a bien
sûr la responsabilité d'anticiper toutes
ces hypothèses
pour cela la france dispose désormais
d'une gamme complète d'outils que la loi
nous permet d'activer jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet cette capacité à agir ne
signifie évidemment pas que nous sommes
tenus d'activer ces mesures de
restriction aussi longtemps que la loi
nous y autorise cela n'aurait aucun sens
il faut savoir réagir vite quand c'est
nécessaire mais il faut aussi savoir
lever les mesures dès que les conditions
permettent de le faire cela vaut aussi
pour le pass vaccinale ça nécessitait je
les dis ne fait aucun doute aujourd'hui
mais je veux être clair le pass pourrait
tout à fait être suspendue si la
pression épidémique et surtout
hospitalière venait à se réduire
fortement et durablement si nos services
de réanimation ne voyait plus arriver de
nouveaux malades pendant plusieurs
semaines si nos hôpitaux n'était plus
obligé de déprogrammer des soins si la
cites pression sanitaire redescendre est
au plus bas alors nous serions amenés à
lever le pass tout en nous tenant
évidemment prêts à leur est activé en
cas de redémarrage
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens voici les orientations et
les perspectives que je souhaitais
partager ce soir avec vous nous sommes
incontestablement dans une nouvelle
phase de l'épidémie grâce à nos efforts
collectifs
grâce à la vaccination nous allons faire
face à la vague en cours nous devons
être confiants tout en restant très
vigilant
respectueux des autres et des consignes
collectives
mobilisés et plus que jamais solidaires
je vous remercie nous allons maintenant
avec olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé répondre à
vos questions
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
ministre bonjour allison tassin pour tf1
et lci vous annoncé un allègement des
restrictions alors même qu'on parle de
l'arrivée d'un nouveau variant du bea
points 2 plus transmissible comique ron
est déjà présent au royaume uni ne
redoutez vous pas une cinquième vague et
pensez vous tenir coûte que coûte le
calendrier annoncé ce soir et puis vous
avez parlé d'un nouveau protocole dans
les écoles un allègement après les
vacances quand pouvez vous pensez vous
pouvoir donner ce nouveau protocole et
donc quelle échéance avez vous pour la
lance de ceux de son nouveau protocole
pour les écoles merci be nice
bonsoir oui alors il ya des variants
assez régulièrement
l'om est classe d variant en fonction de
leurs caractéristiques de contagiosité
de dangerosité de risque des chefs de
d'échappement à la vaccination le
vaillant auquel vous faites allusion est
un sou variant issus de mikron on trouve
essentiellement au danemark on trouve
aussi au royaume uni on l'a identifié
par techniques de séquençage sur le
territoire national pour ce que nous
savons pour l'instant d'ailleurs de l'om
et ne l'a pas classé comme un variante
d'intérêt en tout cas pas à ce stade
pour ce que nous savons il correspond
peu ou prou aux caractéristiques que
nous connaissons de mikron et il n'y a
pas à ce stade de connaissances sur des
risques de contagiosité vis-à-vis de
celles et ceux qui auraient déjà
contracté le variant omicron dont il
ferait partie pardonnez-moi de la gamme
des sous-groupes du variant mikron et ne
change pas la donne ce qui est
fondamental c'est qu'on est au garde une
surveillance à l'échelle planétaire très
rapprochés via les techniques de
séquençage on fait beaucoup en europe
beaucoup en france un peu moins dans
d'autres pays mais quand même l'afrique
du sud nous a montré qu'elle était
capable de diagnostiquer tôt invariants
comme omicron donc le 6 avr est nouveau
variant devait arriver issu d'une
nouvelle souche par exemple avec des
caractéristiques différentes ce que
personne ne souhaite je vous le dis tout
de suite et bien nous puissions réagir
rapidement comme nous avons été amenés à
le faire en retardant l'apparition de
vagues épidémiques donc on s'inscrit
dans une dune durée comme le dit le
premier ministre avec des outils qu'on
est capable d'activer lorsqu'il faut le
faire pour freiner coupé mais qu'on est
aussi capable de lever lorsque la
situation nous semble davantage sous
contrôle
s'agissant de votre
deuxième question je vais y faire ce que
j'indiquais donc le protocole actuel va
rester en vigueur puisque nous avons
aménagé adapté dans les conditions que
vous savez sur lesquelles je ne
reviendrai pas jusqu'à sortie des
classes il ya trois zones vous le savez
tout ça et donc nous profiterons de ce
temps pour voir comment les choses
évoluent nous ressaisirons olivier
ferrand les autorités sanitaires puisque
je rappelle que les protocoles notamment
s'agissant de la détermination du nombre
de tests pour l'été à contacter pour les
enfants en particulier sont déterminés
par les autorités sanitaires ndour nous
les ressaisiront pouvoir dans quelle
mesure à la rentrée donc pour quelques
semaines devant nous nous pourrons
adapter le dispositif
entre question
va peut-être en train de vous croire la
suite comme on le fait d'habitude
bonsoir monsieur monsieur premier
ministre messieurs les ministres
elisabeth lomé pour bfm tv une précision
par rapport à ce que vous venez de dire
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
dit que le pass vaccinale pourrait être
suspendue si la pression épidémique se
réduisait sur quels critères sanitaires
vous basez vous est ce qu'il faut est ce
qu'il faut prendre en compte le taux
d'incidence le nombre de contaminations
par jour est-ce que vous avez vous
envisagé d'introduire des seuils est-ce
que vous pouvez nous apporter des
précisions sur cette éventuelle levée du
passé ni terre et j'ai une nouvelle
phase du pad vaccinale pardon et j'ai
une nouvelle précision à vous demander
concernant la levée du protocole dans
les écoles en tout cas son allégement
les vacances sont effectivement en
échelonné est ce que vous envisagez du
coup de le lever à partir de la reprise
des cours pour la première donne donc
fin février le 21 février de mémoire où
ça sera une mesure au niveau national
qui débutera donc en mars merci
autre question en 1 2 3 et on répondra
georges à la mi-mars au pour la fp
pouvez vous nous expliquer pourquoi vous
ne fixer aucun critère épidémiologique
finalement pour lever les restrictions
de février au 16 est-ce que tout s'est
levé sont considérées comme acquises
troisième ep en réponse au piano pas
bonjour l abonné pour essayer tf1 vous
avez parlé de la réouverture des
discothèques à partir du 16 février ce
que le masque le port du masque sera
obligatoire à ce moment là dans les
discothèques
merci à plusieurs questions pour vous je
compléterai oui il est plusieurs
questions qui ont été posées d'abord sur
les indicateurs des critères pour le
pass vaccinale
ce que nous voulons c'est comme l'a dit
premier ministre la situation sanitaire
soit stabilisée sous contrôle que nous
voulons ce qu'il n'y ait plus de soin
des programmes et ce que nous voulons ce
qui n'est pas des médecins qui sont
obligés d'appeler des familles de
malades pour leur dire qu'elle a s'il
n'y a plus de places disponibles pour
pouvoir les opérer en temps et en heure
parce que des lits de réanimation sont
trop nombreux à être occupés par des
patients atteints des formes graves du
code id le pass vaccinale est un outil
de protection un outil qui gonfle qui
permet de booster les primo vaccination
de notre pays est un outil qui réduit
aussi les risques de se contaminer dans
les endroits dans lesquels il se rate
appliquée donc dès lors que la pression
hospitalière est suffisamment base nous
l'avons connu à plusieurs reprises la
dernière fois c'était au mois d'août par
exemple je crois que nous étions
descendus même en dessous des 1000
patients qu'aux vide en réanimation il y
avait une charge hospitalière qui
s'était réduite et la dynamique
épidémique n'était plus là les taux
d'incidence montré que le virus circule
et à bas bruit mais pas fortement celle
des moments où on peut en confiance
lever un certain nombre de mesures qui
aujourd'hui vit ça nous protéger et qui
serait jugée disproportionnée par la
population au regard du risque sanitaire
dont est-ce qu'il faut établir des
critères à la lettre l'histoire
nettement de cette pandémie nous a
montré depuis deux ans que la vérité
d'un jour n'est pas forcément celle du
lendemain
s'il n'y avait pas de nouveaux variants
ce une fois que la vague omicron était
passé nous pourrions nous dire que nous
pouvons à nouveau vivre tranquillement
sans avoir peur qu'émergent de nouvelles
vagues auquel cas nous serions amenés à
relâcher les mesures de contrainte y
compris celles qui passent par le pass
vaccinale si l inverse il y avait des
menaces épidémie qui se faisait jour on
en parlait tout à l'heure avec votre
collègue il ya quelques minutes s'il y
avait un nouveau variant qui devait
apparaître forcément ça pourrait changer
la donne même si la pression sanitaires
étaient plus faibles donc on a on
appliquera le passé actional aussi
longtemps que nécessaire mais pas plus
longtemps que nécessaire de la même
manière vous poser la question pourquoi
le 7 février je me permets de répondre
ces prémices dans la continuité pourquoi
le 2 février
le 2 février ça fera une semaine que le
pass vaccinale sera en vigueur pourquoi
le passage final dans les établissements
qui reçoivent du public les restaurants
les bars les cinémas et bien dès lors
qu'on aura au moins une semaine de
retour on sait que le pass vaccinale
sera bien accepté bien contrôlé bien mis
en place le risque de contamination sera
considérée comme suffisamment faible
pour qu'on puisse relâché aujourd'hui
des mesures restrictives comme les
jauges que par exemple ou d'autres
mesures qui pourront à ce moment là être
abandonné et deux semaines plus tard je
dirais les situations les plus à risque
pourquoi deux semaines plus tard parce
qu'on considère que aux alentours de la
mi février non seulement on devrait
avoir largement passé le pic épidémique
de mikron mais que si on se calque sur
la situation de nos voisins britanniques
par exemple on sera sans doute déjà
descendu beaucoup plus bas en termes de
nombre de contacts de contamination par
jour il a déjà énormément circuler le
variant au micro est ce que nous montre
l'exemple franciliens en ile-de-france
que ça a commencé à baisser c'est que ça
va finir par baisser dans tout le pays
et donc trois semaines de recul on est
un peu plus un peu plus serein pour se
dire on peut relâcher encore d'autres
contraintes et permettre aux gens de
retrouver la vie la plus normale
possible pourquoi pas mangé debout dans
les bars où aller danser dans les
discothèques et sur le masque dans les
tec et sur le masque dans les
discothèques nous verrons s'il ya lieu
ou non ça ça dépendra probablement par
exemple de la situation épidémique au
moment où la décision sera prise
véritablement de rouvrir et discothèques
on prendra pas de risques inutiles
l'objectif c'est de permettre aux
français de profiter des discothèques
l'objectif c'est aussi de permettre aux
patrons du monde de la nuit qui vont
enfin rouvrir les discothèques d'être
sûr de pouvoir le faire en confiance
donc si la situation sanitaire le permet
évidemment on n'imposera pas le masque
si en revanche on est un peu limite à ce
moment-là peut-être contré amené à me
demander de le conserver encore quelques
jours ou quelques semaines
rappelant bien le temps que vous passiez
les micros à champagne la finalité la
philosophie de ses passes double je le
rappelle à tous nos concitoyens
elle consiste d'abord à éviter des
mesures de fermeture le pass sanitaire
la paire ni le pass lac signale encore
davantage et à 1,6 tu es très fortement
à la vaccination puisque maintenant on
connaît mieux omicron la bonne nouvelle
encore une fois c'est la très forte
décrue de delta dans la dangerosité et
intérêts et on sait que avec omicron
quelques dangereux quelques contagieux
pardon qu'il soit nous savons qu'avec un
schéma vaccinal complet notamment trois
doses et forcément comme je vous l'avais
dit le pass vaccinale mallet inciter
encore davantage ce qui reste toujours
la pierre d'achoppement forte
c'est-à-dire les capacités hospitalières
seront moins mobilisés
juste une petite précision sur les
discothèques puisque manifestement c'est
la grande inquiétude des professionnels
un test négatif sur at il demandé à
l'entrée en plus du post vaccinale
des autres questions faire venir
peut-être faite par mag bonjour
merci à nouveau allison tassin pour tf1
et lci vous n'avez pas évoquer la fin du
masque en intérieur est-ce que vous avez
une visibilité là tu es ce que cette ce
port du masque en intérieur pourrait
intervenir avant ou après la fin du pass
vaccinale est ce que l'art est
conditionnée à l'autre merci tu viens
donc vous vivez sur le site de questions
sanitaires l'une sur le leader je
m'attendais quand vous avez évoqué les
discothèques plutôt que le masque que
vous posiez d'emblée celle sur les tests
qui s'ajouterait donc aux passes
rappelons bien que le passe évidemment
vaccinale sera imposée à l'entrée des
discothèques donc à la question parce
que ça se pratique dans certains pays je
le dis 'assez' et ce qu'ils écoutent d'y
ajouter la nécessité d'un test et puis à
la question du max qu un extérieur ce
ministre mais il ya deux éléments alors
d'abord c'est ce que vous appelez le
pass 2 g + qui le passe à l'allemande
c'est parce vaccinale plus test depuis
moins de 24 heures négatif la loi nous
permet de le faire dans la loi pour
voter les parlementaires il est inscrit
la possibilité d'adapter les conditions
d'application du pôle personal mais nous
n'avons pas l'ambition de le faire en
tout cas pas en l'état nous considérons
que de pouvoir ouvrir les discothèques
avec suffisamment maintenant de recul
face à la menace que constitue omicron
pour pouvoir le faire si jamais la
situation devait évoluer encore une fois
prudents ne ressortait pas la vidéo en
trois semaines pour dire qu'on aurait
dit inverse on sait jamais ce qui peut
arriver mais telle est l'intention
actuellement est la même pour le masquer
en intérieur le masque en intérieur est
quand même encore une petite protection
nécessaire surtout quand on a beaucoup
de contamination au quotidien quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe à l'étranger
quand on parle de l'exemple anglais est
un peu le groupe contrôle en
l'occurrence parce qu'ils ont levé
toutes les restrictions d'un seul coup
mais regardez l'allemagne qui aime
beaucoup plus de mesure aujourd'hui de
contrainte et qui pourraient renforcer
parce que eux sont dans la phase
ascendante de la vague au micro regardez
l'italie qui a mis en place en place un
pass vaccinale à la française d'ailleurs
et qui du coup leur permet à l'instar de
ce que nous faisons de réduire les
restrictions mais regardez d'autres pays
les pays bas qui sont encore en
confinement l'autriche qui en sort tout
doucement cédera donc ya pas il n'y a
pas un rythme uniforme sur tout le
territoire européen chacun tire
conséquence de l'expérience acquise de
la situation épidémique et sanitaires au
moment où une prend des mesures nous
nous avons été frappés par une vague
delta plus tardive que nos voisins
européens mais très forte et qui a
rempli nos hôpitaux etc a rempli nos
services de réanimation c'est pour ça
que nous sommes obligés d'être un peu
plus prudent que certains des voisins
qui ont été touchés très fortement aussi
mais qui ont connu une vague delta plus
précoce et qui a eu le temps de se
réduire avant que la vague au micro ne
démarre donc on adapte les choses mais
pour répondre à votre question
aujourd'hui on conserverait le masque en
intérieur on appliquerait pas vaccins
plus test d'un risque au tac merci
beaucoup dames les messieurs
en soirée
m